من جانبه يشهد الرئيس الصيني السجن بينغو
مستوى التعاون الصيني الخليجي وقال انه
يعد بافاق الواسعه في شتى المجالات وتحدث
الرئيس شيفينغ عن وجود درجه العاليه من
التكامل بين الطرفين ما يجعل منهما شريكين
طبيعيين للتعاون
فنجان قهوه
عميقه متبادله بين الجانبين اذا ان الصين
ولا مجلس التعاون الخليجي
تتبادلان دوما الدعم لمبدا سياده الدول
واستقلالها
تحترم طروقها التنمويه وتتمسك بالمساواه
بين جميع الدول سواء كانت صغيره او كبيره
وتدافع بحجم عن تعدديه الاطراف هناك درجه
عاليه من التكامل بين الجانبين في الصين
تتمتعوا بسوق استهلاكه واسعه ومنظومه
صناعيه متكامله بينما يتميز الجانب
الخليجي بموارد الطاقه الغنيه
والتطوري المزدهر لتنويع الاقتصاد ما يجعل
منهما شاركين طبيعيين للتعاون